when you do all mail-in voting ballots
you're asking for fraud people steal
them out of mailboxes
people print them and then they sign
them and they give them in that the
people don't even know whether they're
double counted but in California the
governor sent I hear Ora sending
millions of ballots all over the state
to anybody people that aren't citizens
we're not going to destroy this country
by allowing things like that to happen
now President Trump is not the first to
warn about the potential for massive
amounts of fraud from mail-in ballots
the bipartisan Commission on federal
election reform was co-chaired but that
by that noted right winger Jimmy Carter
okay well it found in 2005 that absentee
ballots remain the largest source of
potential voter fraud citizens who vote
at home at nursing homes at the
workplace or in church are more
susceptible to pressure overt and subtle
or to intimidation vote buying schemes
are far more difficult to detect when
citizens vote by mail joining me now is
Texas lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
dan the geniuses at Twitter subjected
Trump to their first ever fact check but
in your state a recent two-year
investigation
didn't you guys uncover an alleged
ballot harvesting scheme involving
mail-in ballots well we found many over
the years Laura but this story just
broke tonight literally I think you're
the first person to talk about it and
calling Vera who I know very well a very
good citizen investigative reporter
spent two years on this she found where
a Democrat congresswoman in Houston paid
a convicted forger and there was another
convicted forger working on this
campaign they also have audio tapes of
them talking about how they can harvest
these ballots group them up in groups of
50 the signatures were the same on the
envelope as as they were on every one of
these ballots and the ballot signatures
so look Twitter owes the president an
apology they fact-checked him Laura for
his opinion and by the way his opinion
was based on fact because the Democrats
are trying to steal this election I just
tweeted
that the democrat plan to have everyone
vote by males an invitation for fraud
and it's a total scam and tonight I
would like all of your millions of
viewers to tweet their own tweet out
about how mail-in ballots are a scam by
the Democrats let's see if Twitter fact
checks me and the millions of people
remember that movie Network when Howard
Beale said oh you go to the window and
and and and just shout out you're mad as
hell you're not gonna take it anymore
well the modern day is go to your
computer millions of tweets how the
Democrats plan your rights our own tweet
folks send it out and let's see if
Twitter goes after them like they went
after the president they owe him an
apology
no he's not gonna get it from Jack well
they need fact-checking opinion yeah
well I think in effect so I think in
effect check all the modelers who were
wrong during the Cova door they can
affect all of the people who are wrong
but all their doomsday scenarios Jerry
Nadler by the way congressman liberal
from New York said this Dan in 2004
watch in my experience in New York paper
ballots are extremely susceptible to
fraud I want a paper trail I want paper
somewhere but pure paper with no
machines I can show you pre I can show
you experience which head-spinning a
blur I've lost a little weight since
then but the weight of his comments are
just on target there and Laura I was one
of the co-authors of our voter ID bill
when I was a senator before becoming
lieutenant governor and that's what the
Democrats said on the floor we don't
have to have photo voter ID because the
scam is in the mail and ballots they
know that that's why they're trying to
have everyone vote by mail look here's
the deal the further away Laura you get
from the ballot box the more opportunity
for fraud the Democrats used to say you
don't have to you know show an ID to
vote now they don't even want you to
vote and as far as protections they say
this is about safety it has nothing to
do with safety because 60 because 65
years old and older citizens in this
country in Texas in almost every state
can already vote by mail what the
Democrats want to do is automatically
send out ballots which is against the
law in Texas you have to request them to
vote by mail and they want to send it
out to every
citizen this is this is their
opportunity to try and rig the election
we're not going to put up with it and if
they get away with it Laura if they get
it's the end of democracy it's not just
the the end of this presidential
campaign if they get away with this
democracy has been shredded well I
remember when we were hailing Iraqis for
going into the poll to vote for the
first time with their purple fingers
they risk their lives to vote it was so
important to them we can do it safely in
person everybody's done it through the
history of the country if you really
need an absentee ballot for you know
real reasons you can get it but this is
this is a complete Democrat scam 100%
dan thank you so much